this is Thomas sold absolutely wrecking
affirmative action you often hear people
say well affirmative action may be
unfair but it's helped a lot of people
you buy that it may have helped some
people but on net balance I don't
believe it has there's a marvelous study
done uh showing that when they banned
affirmative action in California uh
University of California system blacks
began to graduate at a much higher rate
than before graduate with much higher
grade point average graduated in
subjects like math and Engineering to a
far greater extent than before because
now the students went to those
particular parts of the University
system that fitted their particular
academic preparation and they graduated
before you know you could flunk out of
Berkeley or UCLA which does you no good
now you can graduate from Davis or Santa
Cruz and go on to a career isn't that
something if you put people at schools
that they should be in that match up
with their skills they actually will do
better in life